نحن هنا في مدينه زا بويشيا امام مركز
للمساعدات النازحين هنا خصص هذا المركز
للنازحين القادمين من مدينه انرجي» مدينه
التي تبعد عنه 50 كم وتوجد بها المحطه
النوويه الاكبر في اوروبا في هذا المركز
يستطيع النازحون الحصول على المساعدات
الغذائيه على الفراش وعلى استشاره نفسيه
ايضا
الينا متطوعه في المركز هربت عندما احتل
الجيش الروسي المدينه
يعاني المركز من نقص في مواد النظافه لا
نحصل على ما يكفي من المتبرعين نفس الشيء
مع البطانيات والملابس الدافئه على سبيل
المثال تلقينا 200 من هذه المساعدات
ونحاول معرفه كيفيه تقسيمها على 5000 شخص
نحن ممتمون جدا للمركز على المساعده
الغذائيه التي يقدمها لنا وايضا على
المناشف وطعام الاطفال
نحن حقا ممتنون لهم
هذا المخزن مليء بالمساعدات الانسانيه هنا
مساعدات جاءت من داخل يوكانيا هنا مساعدات
جاءت من الدنمارك اما هنا فهي مساعدات
جاءت من الصليب الاحمر الفرنسي اوليكسي
عضو في المجلس البلدي لمدينه
وموظفون في محطه الطاقه النوويه هرب في
بدايه شهر تموز يوليو عندما تم اخباره
بانه يبحثون عنه الاعتقاله
النوويه
والبعض الاخر لا يزال في السجن
[موسيقى]
70% من سكان مدينه
ومازال العمال الاوكراني يدورون المحطه
ويعملون بها تحت سيطره ومراقبه الجيش
الروسي فبدون خبرهم ومعرفتهم فان خطب وقوع
حادث النووي سيكون مرتفعا جدا